こんにちははじめさそうです私以前の動画である
ゴルフクラブを
へし折ってしまいました僕が被ってしまったゴルフクラブなんですけれども
北ゴルフをやったことがなくてゴルフがどんなものかって
全く知らなくてちょっと使用用途ともわからず僕の間違った使い方でゴルフクラブを
打ってしまいました
いろんなご迷惑おかけしてしまったので実はなぁとすぎ起きろとゴルフさんと連絡を
とり直接ヒルド pro 3を訪問させていただき
僕とズームその形で謝罪させていただきましたで今回なぜこのようなことになったかと
いいますとまずそもそも僕にゴルフの
知識がなかったまつげ学そこだと思っておりますその結果
ゴルフしている方なら誰アクションは大切にするゴルフクラブってもの平昌ってしまっ
たんですけれども
色た頃さんと話し合った結果改めてなるゴルフウザーキングを提供していただけました
本当にありがとうございますそして申し訳ないです膝コロさんいい形で知識がないから
仕方ないというツイートもやはりすごい
迷惑をかけてしまったので今回キロとヴォルフさん直々にぜひこの私肇社長にコトロ
セッティングの正しい使い方をみなさんに広めてほしいというわけで白と黒2の取材し
た後実はゴルフのレッスンを受けまくっておりました
どうぞあの北ゴルフクラブまともに最もと同じ全くやった事がないのでゼロからの
スタートだったんですけれども
ばよい
みっちり練習させていただきました初めてたぜ
まったくやり方わかんないです0だから本当にゼロから今からメスオフ
どこまで上達できるかを見せてやろうと思ううっぱらっと
映画でそれ本当に当て落とせた
食べようとした
しています
rar ん
aname
野球
このグランツ
fall プロヴァンスましたうんそれでいいと思いますよだから難しいつねる
よろしくお願い爪がしますね
この打ち方も1月
cm でございます
運営です hoop shorts 4
me
duhan
に巻かれるのは甘え方をやりますすごいっ
me
を持ち上げます永田ない
[音楽]
はい今どこ振ってればなって前です手前かつ上降ってる
つまり
ボールの高さぎするためには4日
体を前に倒した同期たら動かない
まれに倒した者が版が出るかどうか
ピザを憂えていましたーーー
than ん
[音楽]
当たるためには今
ヘッドがスポットそしてっ
はいというわけでついじめを破ったんですけども6寿司
引き続き愛して続けていきたいとおもいます
4分
e 層から入ると思いましてねぇ
足を収集
しっかり方も回って腰も回転していて感心はスウェーしてないですね右に流れてない
ですね
下半身がしっかり先行している状態で腕も伸びていい形してまーす決して悪くないです
ねもう
姿勢として
ええええええ
しまった
ポリから自慢です
ああああああ
5時から防止なるように使うんですけれどもそのときにこの後 the working
内なる頃スクラブがジャストミートしてるっていう練習のときにすごい役立つ
嬉しいでございます
3種
ライブいいじゃ
今は緩いですから休学者向けますからここまで来ると
まあゼロから始めたんでまあ僕がどこまで接続したが消えるところです
最初にです行くぞ
おっさんは最終日なんでどうぞよろしくお願いします
そういうシナリオ感じと
すごくして
はい逆に別の動きをしています
これで周遊 h
必要ん
うーんう
潔癖でっっ
思います ben
[音楽]
わっ
tee
goo ん
mhf
tan
ん
危ないと思う
まーうんぐらい
打ててくればまあボンドを打ちながらっていう感じになってくれたら
今エースには一応当てるパッキンになって言っちゃうし
まあ上物イヤーパッドまあ
スイングだね形としてはコわりときれいくれるようになるか
まぁまだまだボールの感じなくなりました
当たる感覚っていうのはもう少し付
と思ってるよりも運動神経いいと思ってスマートフォンと色だけがんばって練習できる
かって言うと思いますよ
はいもうすぐ右に行くんだよそこを自分なをすればそうですねこの右に行くのはゴール
ファーウェイの悩み
アヅマ本当にスライス右
ボールは悩んだんですが以上
ん0本と表製品で予約入っ
入っています
愛剣でいかがだったでしょうかこれで初めてだったんですけどめちゃくちゃ難しかった
ねねんともうねあとの時がめっちゃ来て気持ちいいクリーンヒットするときバトルん
ですよかるーく振るだけですよから来るだけでいいんですけれどもこのゴルフ9ある年
形でをしっかり使って当てるのか大事なのでそのゴルフクラブよりしなりを感じやすい
ので鉱物時にしなりを感じながら打ってるっていう素晴らしい練習気分になっており
ますのでこれでは実際売ってるんですけれどもシナリオ感じる練習になるので僕はまだ
シナリオ関することがうまくできないのでこれがすごい練習に役立つものとなっており
ますあのー
マジでゴルフにはまってしまいそうです今度期末イベントはとっとと日メッツ今日キー
んで
なんてことをしてしまったんだと今か白ところさんのおかげでをしてゴルフに触れる
機会があったのでぜひ今後もごれで続けていければいいなと思っております
6な力をかける取るんですけど普通に使っていたら折れないのでうちパトナ漱石毎晩
行きたいぐらいの勢いなんですけど本当に貴重な経験をさせていただけましたしなる頃
いくら正しいよとでっかいでしょじゃあ
[音楽]